哎，
我有几个问题想要问你一下，
我想知道我应该就是如何转变自己的，
就是对婚姻的这样一种个人的恐惧和一种就是有一点极端的态度吧，
我觉得对于我目前的状况来看呢，
就是不结婚应该是不太可能的，
因为我父母这边就是就我不可能反抗，
但是我对婚姻确实非常的恐惧和抵触，
我自认为是一个性格很差的人，
也与我的部分成长经历有关，
我一直对于那种亲密关系是那种非常作，
然后说话很难听，
就是那种通过伤害别人来就是证明对方爱我的那种很作的那种类型，
就是比如说我其实是我错了，
然后我会让对方难受，
我会让他觉得他难受，
他痛哭的那种，
我才会罢休，
才会不再生气，
然后我也是非常的抗拒婚姻这种束缚，
因为我觉得父母得的这样的，
他们俩的婚姻对我来说是没有一个榜样的，
我觉得可能是因为这方面的关系，
但我并不恨他们，
就是我觉得父母可能是已经习惯了吧，
就是我并不觉得他们曾经对我做的一些是什么特别重大的伤害，
但是比如说我小时候，
我的母亲会说，
如果你要是个男孩的话。
把你们家的人会更爱你这样的话，
然后考差了会把我关到小黑屋里面，
我的母亲也是，
就是追难保多年没有成功，
然后比如说我回家晚了，
他会把我的作业本撕掉，
小时候把我和一个诚异性的表情放在一起，
然后就发生了一些你想说的事情，
比如说我刚上班的时候，
他会以断绝关系等等去给我相亲之类的，
但是我妈妈好的一点是，
她会就是给我钱，
就是可能在这方面弥补了我一些伤害。
然后我的父亲呢，
小时候她在家里的时间很短，
她不太会为家里付出，
在我的印象中是这样的一个，
比如说一些开支啊，
需要给他账单，
他肯定才会给，
大学的时候，
嗯，
就没有给我一分钱，
就出了学费，
学费就是那种有零有整，
都不会多一块钱，
但是我不知道她会不会给我妈妈，
但是我的印象中他是不会，
包括我现在就是为了他们俩的愿望到了家这边上班，
但是父亲现在变得对我非常的冷漠，
我不知道为什么，
我的家里就是这样的一个情况，
然后我对婚姻就是特别的抗拒，
就是我之前是觉得我不想结婚，
但是没有这么的抗拒，
后来我谈了一个男朋友，
就两三个月，
然后他就。
所有的事情都是骗我的，
然后在第三个月发现的时候，
我们就分手了，
然后从那个时候开始，
我就对男人特别的讨厌，
就是非常的讨厌，
就讨厌的那种啊，
感觉他们说的话都是假的那种，
给你看，
就是有什么对我的一些建议嘛，
但是其实我说的这些就是像评论区说的和我的生活环境有关，
一开始说像什么卖淫之类的，
我觉得我都没有什么关系，
其实我对我父母现在也挺就是挺平静的，
这些事情我会想起来，
在我读大学的时候，
我可能会就半夜里就是哭一顿就好了，
然后我现在其实已经完全平静下来了，
包括就是他撕掉的那些作业本啊，
然后什么的我都会偷偷的藏起来，
就偶尔就是收拾家里的时候，
我会翻出来看一下，
我当时写了些什么，
就是其实我已经完全的把这些事情放下了，
但是我确是对婚姻有一些恐惧，
嗯，
我害怕就是跟一个人束缚在一起，
然后接受对方的家庭这样子，
那其实啊，
就好多女孩子都会跟你有相同类似的这种感受，
害怕亲密关系，
害怕把自己真实的样子展示给别人看，
对爸爸妈妈也不是很亲近，
或者说心里带着一些儿时的伤害，
且好多女孩子跟你有相同类似的这种心境。
呃，
你怎么才能够去面对这件事情？
第一，
恐惧婚姻，
恐惧两个人相处这件事情，
本身接纳他对我就是害怕婚姻，
我就是害怕两个人相处，
我接纳他，
因为我害怕婚姻，
因为我害怕两个人相处，
所以我会更加谨慎的保护自己，
反而可能基于你对婚姻的恐惧，
对男生的恐惧，
你在以后的成长路上减少了很多风险，
减少了很多对自己再次带来伤害的可能性，
这是我能想到的。
对于这些所有的女孩子，
就是你害怕她，
恐惧她这件事情，
那我内心深处我接纳自己这一点，
接纳自己这一点了之后，
我一点一点的去求证，
在我害怕的恐惧的这些人当中，
是不是有真的心地很善良的，
真的很想对我好的，
真的是我需要的，
真的也是他需要我的，
有这样的缘分的人，
一点一点去求证，
一点一点去接触啊，
但是千万不要走入另一个极端，
另一个极端是什么？
就是你的爸爸妈妈相中了一个人，
这个人本身没毛病，
各方面都挺好，
对你也很好，
也很满意，
然后你是基于没有办法反抗爸爸妈妈跟人家走入这段婚姻，
走入这段婚姻的目的就是想过得不好。
证明爸爸妈妈是错的，
证明爸爸妈妈当初逼你是不应该的，
千万不要走入这样的一个极端，
你明白王菲姐表达这个意思吗？
就是或许你的爸爸妈妈可能不是一个合格的父母，
不是一个优秀的父母，
但是或许他们的看人的眼光，
呃，
考察人的标准，
以及他们对你的了解，
可能比你自己也要更了解，
所以或许有一天他们选的那个人，
打设的那个人真的很喜欢你，
对你很好，
你千万不要带着说我非得证明我爸妈是错的，
然后日子就往差了过，
非得对人家不好，
非得什么事儿对吧？
怎么说呢，
什么事儿都是往坏了去搞，
你，
你要这么搞的话，
就没有人能够真正跟你好好的相处下去了。
所以这事儿就是带着我对婚姻的恐惧，
带着我对男生的恐惧，
一点一点去了解，
一点一点去接触，
去求证。
首先啊，
就他本身，
你别看他对你怎么样，
你看看他对周围的，
比如说对快递小哥，
对服务员，
对打扫卫生的清洁的大姐，
对这些比他弱的人到底怎么样，
你看看他对那些小动物，
呃，
受伤了对吧？
他态度怎么样？
如果是人家本身就是一个很善良，
很有爱心且非常喜欢你的人的话，
如果你再去伤害他，
通过伤害他来寻求自己的一种安全感的话，
那我只能说啊，
你这么搞的话，
你真的你得不到幸福，
你该对这个逻辑吗？
嗯，
我知道。
就是如果确认对方就是一个很好的很善良的人，
你首先要做的一件事情就是你不要伤害他，
就是因为我也放下了曾经的这些，
就是让我不开心的事情，
然后就是我也慢慢的在想，
嗯，
既然我之前那么的难过伤心，
为什么要让一个嗯，
很好的人，
他去体会我这样的就是莫名其妙的情绪，
是吧，
我觉得还是要就是愉快的相处，
好好生活吧，
也是一颗善良的心来看待这件事情，
如果他没有做错什么事情，
如果他只是因为喜欢我，
他只是比如说听从了父母的安排，
要跟我相亲，
要跟我怎么怎么样，
然后他真的喜欢我，
对我也不错的话，
最起码我要做一个善良的人，
就是我不要去戳人家心窝子，
我不要伤人家自尊，
我不要说那些话，
让人家觉得人家很差劲，
让人家没自信，
让人家以后对女人都反感了，
对女人都厌女了，
我千万不要做那样的事情就对了。
刚刚有一个姐妹说，
就是庆幸我们家没有一个男孩，
其实我也是，
就是很多年都这么庆幸过，
因为我小时候可能三四岁吧，
我就记得我妈妈跟我说，
就是如果你是一个男孩的话，
你爸爸你婆婆会更爱你之类的，
就是这种话，
就是在我的印象中就真的挥之不去，
然后自己。
你这方面的话，
既然知道自己心里面有很多破碎的东西啊，
这个世界上没有人有义务帮我们缝补我们心里的破碎，
也不要寄希望于父母会幡然悔悟，
父母会来道歉，
不要有这样的希望，
就是我们是我们心里的那个就是裁缝，
我们是我们自己这颗心的最牛的一个裁缝，
我们要找到我们心里的那个裂痕，
找到心里的那个漏洞，
我们自己去一点点把这个心里的东西给他补起来，
然后我妈妈比如说现在还会说什么，
他说就是你结婚之后肯定是要生男孩子的，
这样的话，
他们说他们的你自己凭借你自己的感受，
你不要去受你妈妈的这样一个影响吧，
嗯，
啊，
就是我还有一个问题，
就是我有一个相处的，
就是现在还可以的一个男朋友，
然后我想让你帮我，
还有姐妹们帮我看一下，
就是是不是合适的，
我们俩都是在那种西南地区，
然后108线城市的那种小县城，
然后我是九九年初的，
嗯，
她是九九年末的，
我是那个211毕业，
然后他是一个专科学校的本科生，
我们俩是一起考进现在这个单位的，
就是我们都是稳定的体育内的工作是一个单位，
就是我的父亲是一个。
夫气的领导，
然后妈妈是高级教师，
家里面有一个妹妹，
就是很普通的房子，
超级都是有的，
然后对方的话是父母做生意，
年入可能有个100~300个吧，
大概的话，
然后在当地是比较有名的，
家乡是隔壁区县，
就是我跟他相处目前看来还是可以的，
就是他是一个非常持球的男生，
他跟我说他选择我是因为我善良勇敢，
其实我都是打问号的，
其实我有时候都在想，
是不是我之前过得太苦了，
就是心理状况太差了，
嗯，
我才会遇到就是这么好的一个男人，
就是他可以能们在一起，
就是快三年了吧，
然后每天都像报备那样子，
就算我一条都不回他，
他都会跟我讲100条以上，
就是我很多次都觉得是不是上天看到我太苦了，
之前心理状况太差了，
就是之前无数次的想，
就是重开的时候，
然后把他送到我身边来了，
现在有一个问题，
就是他跟我是一个单位的，
然后我们俩现在地下嘛，
我不喜欢就是别人开我们的玩笑，
所以我们一直都没有跟其他人讲，
但是呢，
就是我经炒看姐姐的这个视频，
就是说其实你看一个男生，
你要看他结婚生孩子之后你才能看清楚。
出他对方是个什么样子的人，
和对方的家庭是什么样子的，
就是我目前觉得他还行，
就是我不知道该怎么去，
不知道是考验他还是去观察他，
对于我自己的认知和我的这种就是比较局限的思维来看，
我不知道他是不是适合我的，
就是有些东西互为因果，
怎么理解这个事情呢？
就比如说他给你发100条消息，
你只回他一条，
某种程度上的话，
你觉得他心里会不会有一些失落，
会不会有难过，
会不会有积攒各种各样的怨气，
他会失落，
他也会跟我说，
让我理理他，
嗯，
但是有时候是因为忙，
可能有时候是我，
就是情绪上来了，
就是我想表达的意思是我们结了婚之后，
这个男人他会变成什么样子，
有的时候是互为因果关系，
就除了那种极端的，
他本身就是一个伪装者，
他本身就是一个坏人，
就是一个心特别黑，
特别凉薄的人之外，
我们就说一个正常的人，
他有正常人的这个同情心，
有正常人的同理心，
有正常人的这个人情世故的人，
这个男人结婚之后会用什么方式对待我们，
我们生完孩子之后，
他会用什么方式对待我们，
有很多东西他是互为因果的，
可能跟我们对待他的方式也有关系，
跟我们跟他说话，
相处过程当中的一些。
这些表现也有关系，
所以你说这个事儿有没有一种绝对的方法能够帮你去筛选他，
呃，
他结婚之后一定会对你好，
结婚之后一定会呃，
对你和孩子负责任呢？
我觉得这个世界上没有人可以发明这样一整套的系统，
菲姐，
我写的书，
包括我讲的课程，
只能大概帮你们排除，
比如说有暴力倾向的，
有偏执倾向的性格，
有缺陷的心理，
有各种各样的这种，
呃，
强迫性啊，
或者说情绪黑洞性啊，
这些东西可以帮助你们去排除掉，
但是我没有办法教你们在结婚之后怎么能够让一个男人做到一如既往的对你好，
一如既往的去牵挂你，
去问你去干嘛的，
因为这个东西是互为因果的，
你需要学会去爱他，
你需要学会去为他付出，
你需要学会去体谅他，
去从他的那个角度去感受他的爱，
并且回应他的爱才行。
嗯，
好难啊，
我看到评论区的姐妹都说发消息不花钱，
就是我也是这么觉得，
学会爱别人这件事情对我们来说也是我们自己需要去完成的一个功课，
这个功课可能有一些比如说爸爸妈妈关系很好，
情感很好的人会成为他的一个模板，
那么这些人会更容易学会去爱别人，
像。
如果我们从爸爸妈妈身上没有看到相互爱给予是什么样子的话，
我们就需要自己去学习怎么爱别人，
嗯，
我觉得我是缺少爱别人的能力，
还有就是自己的一个心态，
不太意识到自己问题，
然后自己去成长，
自己去学，
比如说从你的男朋友身上去学怎么去关心一个人，
怎么去爱一个人，
如果他在外面遇到好吃的东西也知道要给你带回来，
那么你可不可以在你遇到好吃的东西，
好玩儿的东西的时候也给他带回去，
如果他出门了，
去哪里了，
知道给你报备，
那么你出门了，
出差了，
去哪里玩了，
是不是也得给他报备？
爱你的人身上学怎么爱一个人。
好的，
谢谢姐姐，
也谢谢平安区的姐妹，
就是我之前可能一直就是思维比较局限，
然后看到大家的这些评论，
我也觉得就是可能大家的想法都对我特别的有帮助，
希望你能够就学会去爱别人，
首先第一点学会感受别人对你的爱，
然后一点点去模仿，
去爱别人，
在这个过程当中去建立信任，
无论是跟现在的这个男朋友也好，
还是将来的其他异性也好，
我们的目的是一致的。
都是希望自己能够获得幸福。